[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce sens public pour 90 minutes de
débats de reportage et d'expertise vous
connaissez les horaires du lundi au
jeudi à 18h et 22h et la promesse de
l'émission donnée du sens à l'actualité
voici le sommaire de ce 11 janvier
depuis hier soir les Français font leur
calcul combien de mois supplémentaires
vais-je devoir travailler c'est le piège
de la mesure d'âge elle risque
d'occulter tout ce que contient la
réforme des retraites en matière de
pénibilité carrière longue emploi des
seniors au régime spéciaux dans notre
premier débat avec des invités 100%
politiques on va décortiquer certaines
de ces mesures et puis dans la seconde
partie de ce sens public on parle de la
santé des femmes on s'imagine que avoir
mal pendant ces règles c'est normal donc
si c'est normal pourquoi est-ce qu'on va
faire des recherches pour améliorer la
vie des femmes je pense aussi qu'il doit
y avoir peut-être y a pas assez de
femmes chercheuses tu devrais peut-être
y en avoir un peu plus
aussi c'est parce que c'est un problème
féminin ce serait un problème masculin
je pense qu'on aurait déjà trouvé je
sais pas si on aurait trouvé la solution
mais en tout cas il y aurait des gens
qui auraient travailler à la solution je
pense des maladies comme l'endométriose
qui passe sous les radars du système de
santé des médicaments inadaptés des
tests majoritairesment réalisés sur des
hommes notre médecine et sexy s'en va
détailler ce scandale et ce qui s'est
des solutions avec nos invités tout à
l'heure mais d'abord le jour 2 de la
réforme des retraites Elisabeth borne et
c'est ministre qui partent convaincre
faire de la pédagogie devant les
Français et les sénateurs Fabien ricquer
premier grand oral pour Elisabeth borne
au lendemain de la présentation de sa
réforme des retraites cet après-midi
lors des questions au Gouvernement
devant les sénateurs la première
ministre a défendu un projet de justice
et d'équilibre aujourd'hui chacun le
sait le nombre de personnes qui
travaillent par rapport au nombre de
retraités diminuent menaçant notre
modèle le seul chemin possible c'est
donc de travailler progressivement plus
longtemps c'est la mesure emblématique
de la réforme le report de l'âge légal à
64 ans des 2030 le gouvernement allonge
aussi la durée de cotisation portée à 43
à 8 et à partir de 2027 en contrepartie
l'exécutif vente plusieurs mesures à
destination des plus fragiles
l'augmentation des plus petites pensions
à 1200 euros une meilleure prise en
compte des carrières longues ou hachées
et l'élargissement des critères de
pénibilité mais pas de quoi amadouer les
syndicats qui affichaient désir soir un
front uni contre le projet du
gouvernement pour moi c'est toujours non
pour la CFDT c'est toujours non pour
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
de ce pays c'est non 64 ans c'est non
pourquoi parce que cette réforme qu'on
qualifie d'ailleurs de réformes des
retraites c'est davantage une réforme de
finance publique c'est davantage une
réforme d'équilibre financier sur le
seul dos des travailleurs face à
l'opposition des syndicats le
gouvernement compte sur les voies de la
droite pour faire adopter sa forme au
Parlement dans sa copie finale
l'exécutif reprend en effet l'ensemble
des demandes de LR comme le départ à 64
ans une mesure déjà votée à plusieurs
reprises par la majorité de droite et du
centre au Sénat désormais reprises à son
compte par le gouvernement en réalité
c'est pas nous qui allons voter la
réforme si on la vote du gouvernement
c'est le gouvernement de Madame élysibat
borne qui propose à sa propre majorité
de voter la réforme que nous avons ici
en réalité rédigé puis voté depuis au
moins quatre ans si elle a l'air peut
crier victoire dans les rangs de la
gauche en revanche l'hostilité à la
réforme est totale j'ai l'impression
d'avoir une juge
une juge qui vient délivrer sa peine et
ça sera deux ans
ça sera deux ans de plus ça sera deux
ans de plus pour les auxiliaires de vie
sociale ça sera deux ans de plus pour
les charis ça sera deux ans de plus pour
les camionnettes ça serait deux ans de
plus pour les femmes de ménage cette
réforme là n'améliore pas la vie ni des
salariés ni des retraités au contraire
c'est une régression sociale pour les
Français c'est pour ça qu'effectivement
nous mènerons la bataille une bataille
désormais engagée les syndicats
appellent à une première journée de
grève et de manifestation jeudi 19
janvier
on décortique le contenu de cette
réforme des retraites avec mes invités
politiques comme promis Benjamin Haddad
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes porte-parole
Renaissance députés de Paris Monique
Lubin
bonsoiriste des Landes René Paul Savary
bonsoir bienvenue sénateur LR de la
Marne Mathieu croissanto bonsoir Mathieu
bienvenue à vous éditorialise politique
Benjamin Ada est-ce que le Président de
la République finalement joue son
quinquennat et sa capacité à réformer
surtout avec avec ce dossier des
retraites c'est surtout l'avenir de nos
retraites qui est en jeu notre capacité
à pouvoir les financer à équilibrer ce
système je crois que c'est vraiment un
moment de responsabilité un monde
justice et d'équité aussi pour notre
système on a fait un choix collectif et
déjà longtemps en France d'avoir un
système de retraite par répartition
solidarité c'est un système
intergénérationnel ou les actifs les
cotisés P les cotisants P pour les
retraites des retraités actuels mais ça
demande de pouvoir les financer en
particulier quand on a une démographie
vieillissante en 1960 on avait quatre
actifs pour un retraité il y a 20 ans
c'était à peu près 2 pour un aujourd'hui
c'est un 7 et on passera bientôt à 1,5
bon il faut se réjouir du fait que c'est
lié aussi à une espérance de vie qui
augmente il faut trouver le moyen de le
financer il y a trois leviers c'est pas
compliqué soit on diminue le montant des
retraites et ça on s'y refuse on fait
même l'inverse on revalorise et retraite
minimum à 85% du SMIC c'est-à-dire ils
sont 1200 euros soit on augmente les
cotisations et à ce moment-là dans un
pays qui est déjà qui a déjà le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire le plus élevé
d'Europe un taux de cotisations qui a
28% qui refuse au contraire on veut
essayer de diminuer le coût du travail
c'est ce qu'on a fait dans le
quinquennat précédent pour continuer à
rendre notre pays attractif et créer des
emplois la troisième option c'est
travailler un peu plus que
collectivement plus longtemps c'est ce
qu'on fait je crois que c'est vraiment
un enjeu de responsabilité on va avoir
le temps d'en reparler vous avez pas
tout à fait répondu à ma question je
vous la reposerai plus tard sur la
capacité d'email
mais un mot rapide là-dessus en c'est
très intéressant vous savez c'est le
deuxième mandat d'emmel Macron il se
représentera pas et je crois que là on a
une responsabilité de nous dans notre
majorité de faire des réformes qui ont
longtemps été repoussés par les
majorités successives par manque de
courage donc il y a vraiment un enjeu de
courage politique vous répondez oui
d'une certaine façon Monique lumineux et
René j'ai oublié de dire vous étiez tous
les deux membres du Conseil
d'orientation des des retraites est-ce
que cette réforme elle est inévitable
Monique plus bas est-ce que la la France
peut s'en passer dans tous les cas nous
ne sommes pas dans la situation que
certains veulent bien décrire
aujourd'hui et nous n'en sommes qu'au
début et quelque chose me dit que plus
les jours vont passer et plus on va
entendre des sommes astronomiques que
nous être annoncées
à venir le corps il fait des projections
c'est pas Madame Irma il travaille sur
un certain nombre de de avec un certain
nombre de critères il fait des
projections et qui sont évidemment
particulièrement sensibles à la
situation économique moi je voudrais
juste te rappeler que juste au milieu du
covid les prévisions du corps étaient
dramatiques et finalement on termine
l'année 2021 avec un léger accident
l'année 2022 avec un léger excédent donc
bon moi ce que je vois c'est qu'à
l'horizon 2027 on est sur à peu près 0,4
points de PIB de déficit c'est-à-dire
aller aller à la louche 10 milliards
d'euros mais c'est dix milliards d'euros
il faut les ramener au 350 milliards
d'euros de retraite qui à peu près aussi
qui sont versées tous les ans
c'est-à-dire que on est quand même loin
de la catastrophe annoncée alors je ne
dis pas qu'il ne faut rien faire le
corps justement s'il a été créé c'est
pour être en capacité de regarder
régulièrement où on sent nos régimes de
retraite et pouvoir prendre s'adapter
pouvoir prendre des des mesures mais
mais là tout d'un coup enfin sincèrement
le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron après
avoir dit le contraire quand même en
2019 c'est intéressant de d'écouter ce
qu'il disait faire travailler les gens
jusqu'à 60 plus de 62 ans et disait que
c'était pas possible il a quand même
visiblement
changer d'avis Emmanuel Macron deux ans
et demi voire trois ans de quoi qu'il en
coûte depuis donc c'est peut-être
payer ce quoi qu'il en coûte et pourquoi
on le fait payer par la réforme des
retraites la réalité quand même c'est
que depuis 2018 Emmanuel Macron veut
faire une réforme des retraites la
première il n'a pas pu l'amener à bien
donc là il veut en faire une autre et
les arguments on va tous les avoir quand
vous nous parlez par exemple de de du
choc de génération du choc démographique
le choc démographique c'est à dire vous
savez le nombre de cotisants par rapport
mais il est passé le choc démographique
et il a été amorti par des gains de
productivité ça va plutôt s'améliorer
dans les dans les mois à venir je vais
vous redonner la parole évidemment pour
pour détailler vos arguments mais
j'essaye voilà de faire en sorte que
pour ce premier tour de table tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer rapidement René
Paul Savary on l'a vu dans le reportage
le le de famille Recker c'est cette
réforme c'est un copier-coller de ce que
les sénateurs LR votent depuis quatre
ans ouais copier pas toujours bien
coller mais
largement copié en tout cas nous si vous
voulez par rapport à tous ces enjeux on
est une vision au niveau sénatorial la
majorité c'est l'intérieur une vision et
on pense qu'il faut équilibrer le
système des retraites dans les
projections et déséquilibrée mais avec
un niveau de vie des retraités qui
baissent et nous on veut pas de retraité
pauvre c'est pour ça qu'on s'était
penché sur cette question on voulait pas
travailler depuis des années au-dessus
de 64 ans c'est pour ça qu'on était là
il nous fallait accélérer la réforme
Touraine votée par la gauche qui faisait
une durée de cotisation qui tu aurais
plus longtemps mais si vous ne décalez
pas l'âge de retraite vous faites des
retraités pauvres c'est la raison pour
laquelle il était important quand vous
augmentez la durée de cotisations de
décaler l'âge de départ de la retraite
et on le souhaitait que à 67 ans il est
vraiment une annulation des écoles ce
qui existe déjà on voulait que soit
maintenu donc dans les grandes lignes ça
rentre à cela avec parallèlement à cela
une politique de maintien dans l'emploi
des seniors et on aura l'occasion on va
discuter
qui permet effectivement que dans les
entreprises on prennent en compte le
travail supplémentaire des seniors et
comprennent en compte la pénibilité donc
effectivement c'est la vision proposée
par la majorité sénatoriale depuis
nombre d'années qui a été la base de
cette réforme proposée par Emmanuel
Macron un mot de réponse sur la critique
de Monique Lemas l'humain
benjamindacieux finalement c'est pas une
réforme des retraites c'est plutôt une
une réforme voilà d'équilibre budgétaire
non mais c'est une réforme pour pouvoir
maintenir notre système de retraite par
redistribution le corps nous dit 12
milliards de déficits d'ici 2027 je
rappelle quand même sur un taux de
chômage de 4,5%. donc en plus c'est une
hypothèse de pleine emploi assez
optimiste et si on voit les projections
qui continuent on se retrouve avec des
déficits accumulés à 100 milliards dans
un horizon 2030 encore une fois sur des
projections de plein emploi qui sont pas
intéressant
des retraites pardon nous interrompre on
lui tout le monde la bulle à interpréter
quand même la seule base statistique
scientifique sur lequel le gouvernement
peut s'appuyer de façon responsable pour
pouvoir faire ses projections et après
mener ces réformes de façon responsable
donc après on peut débattre des
paramètres mais la base je dirais
économique sur laquelle est budgétaire
sur laquelle on l'a fait pour pouvoir
préserver le système sinon effectivement
réfléchis à des alternatives moi
j'entends aujourd'hui des voix dans le
débat politique qui propose un système
par capitalisation comme aux États-Unis
ou vous épargnez pour votre propre
retraite vous allez mettre après dans un
fond de pension en bourse nous c'est un
on a fait un choix différent donc après
effectivement il faut être capable comme
l’ont fait tous nos voisins européens et
quand même pas de recette magique
regarde autour de la France on a des
voisins qui sont à 64 65 67 ans nous
aujourd'hui on a le temps de retraite le
plus important au monde et on a un
niveau des retraités qui est plutôt
au-dessus de la moyenne de la population
et donc on veut effectivement comme l'a
dit que le niveau de ses de devis de ces
retraités ne se dégrade pas se dégrade
pas Mathieu j'ai plusieurs choses que
toi vous avez fait la campagne de
Valérie Pécresse
oui j'ai participé à la campagne de
Valéry
et là vous dites on veut plus entendre
on veut plus entendre parler des 65 ans
ah oui oui absolument parce que au
niveau du Sénat on a vraiment travaillé
sur ce scénario qui me parlait qui
permettait d'éviter la majorité
sénatoriales à la fois LR et nos amis de
l'Union centriste donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous étions sur un
scénario qui peut apparaître différent
par rapport à chaque président de la
République
trois représentants de 3 sensibilités
politiques différentes et que depuis 30
ans chaque sensibilité a pris un petit
peu sa part du chantier personne n'a
fait la réforme totale des retraites et
vous ne ferez pas la mère de toutes les
réformes qui saura le système c'est faux
de le dire c'est que ça va équilibrer
pendant 7 ans et c'est très bien comme
ça parce que personne peut faire la mère
de toute la réforme c'est trop gros
chacun en prend un petit bout et donc ce
qui m'étonne c'est de voir que le fait
que chacun en prenne un petit bout soit
pas consensuel vous en avez fait Fillon
on a fait quand Chirac était président
verte l'a fait quand Sarkozy était
présent vous en avez fait en allongeant
les carrières aussi 43 années de
cotisations donc quand vous dites on
peut pas non plus pousser voilà vous
l'avez vous avez aussi poussé les gens à
travailler plus longtemps vous avez
contraint et forcé
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas fait lors du
précédent quinquennat et vous allez le
faire donc ce qui me frappe c'est de
voir de posture de jeux de posture parce
que tout le monde autour de cette table
c'est très bien que un président ne peut
pas faire la réforme totale que chacun
doit prendre un bout chacun doit la
vendre le mieux possible et globalement
ils ont tous les mêmes idées qui est que
sont quand même de faire travailler les
gens plus longtemps jamais on ne parle
de baisser les revenus des retraités
actuels alors qu'on a les retraités qui
sont quand même les plus aisés de l'OCDE
quasiment à part le Luxembourg
mais manuel Macron l'a dit il y a 5 ans
retraite n'est plus synonyme de pauvreté
il les a même mis à contribution les
retraités vous souvenez pour pour la CSG
mais voilà ça c'est à vous on en parle
pas jamais on ne parle de relever les
cotisations sociales parce que il faut
pas augmenter le coût du travail donc il
y a qu'un seul levier sur lequel tout le
monde est d'accord c'est de faire bosser
les actifs plus longtemps
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord sur le
seul levier qui consisterait justement à
faire travailler les gens plus longtemps
aujourd'hui moi je veux quand même
rappeler certaines choses la réforme
Touraine d'abord c'est pas celle-là qui
a allongé de 2 ans c'est la réforme
précédente la réforme Fillon je crois la
réforme Touraine elle a rajouté des
trimestres jusque à la génération 1973
cette réforme aujourd'hui qui est si je
puis dire aggravée de manière brutale
par le projet de loi puisque de 73 de la
génération 73 on va passer à la à la
génération 65 donc c'est quand même
c'est quand même assez brutal et on
arrivera au 172 trimestres au 43 ans
d'ici 2027 au lieu de 2035 c'est ça
l'accélération les gens qui sont nés les
gens qui sont nés en 1965 devront
cotiser 43 ans alors que dans la réforme
Touraine c'est les gens qui sont nés en
1973 alors ces trois trimestres de plus
pour la génération 65 et 66 après sa
descente de trimestre un trimestre avec
quand même une différence notable c'est
qu'on n'est plus à 62 ans on est à 64
ans alors certes on sait on sait que la
plupart des gens prennent leur retraite
et quand ils ont le nombre de trimestres
quand ils atteignent le taux plein mais
il n'empêche que la réforme Touraine
elle permet aussi de partir à 62 ans
certes avec une décote pour ceux qui
n'en peuvent plus ou pour ceux qui n'ont
plus de travail et on en parlera
peut-être né Paul Savary avec l'emploi
avec l'emploi des seniors aujourd'hui ça
ne sera plus possible donc ça va
aggraver la précarité ce que je voudrais
dire aussi c'est que quand on a fait la
réforme Touraine on était à 20 milliards
de déficit là quasiment immédiat on
n'est pas du tout dans la même situation
aujourd'hui est-ce que je voudrais dire
enfin c'est que on est absolument
demande pas obligés de rallonger la fin
de reculer là je départ à la retraite on
peut aussi par exemple arrêter de
défiscaliser et de désocialiser à
outrance toutes les heures
supplémentaires tous les tous les tous
les salaires jusqu'à je ne sais plus
combien 1,6 % du SMIC et ainsi de suite
et on fera rentrer et on fera rentrer
des cotisations retraite il y a d'autres
choses à faire il y a d'autres choses à
faire
ça sur ce dernier point bon déjà je
reconnais qu'à un moment une certaine
cohérence de reconnaître
qu'effectivement on peut peut-être avoir
d'autres leviers qui ait des défis des
équilibrés nous effectivement on a un
désaccord là-dessus on ne veut pas
augmenter les cotisations le coût du
travail on a déjà un coût du travail qui
est suffisamment élevé en France quand
on se compare notamment à nos
partenaires européens c'est 28% de
cotisations c'est 46% de prélèvements
obligatoires on assume complètement le
fait justement d'avoir accès par exemple
vous dites pour les cotisations en
dessous les exemptions pour les
cotisations en dessous d'un virgule 6
points le SMIC on a aujourd'hui le taux
de chômage en France le plus faible en
15 ans le plus élevé en 25 ans la France
est devenue le pays le plus attractif
pour les investissements étrangers
réjouissons-nous de cela et n'allons pas
justement enrayer cette dynamique de
compétitivité en augmentant le coût du
travail et les cotisations et en
baissant le pouvoir d'achat des salariés
dubitatif oui parce que parce que on
montre bien quand on rentre dans le
dossier que on peut jouer sur des
cotisations et ça changerait pas la face
du monde ça représenterait quelques
euros mais sur le plan du nombre ça peut
être significatif c'est pas le choix que
nous avons retenu non plus moi
simplement parce que je veux rappeler je
veux rappeler c'est que la durée moyenne
de retraite alors il y a des
différence selon les métiers les niveaux
sociaux il y aurait moyen on est dans
les grandes lignes c'est maintenant on
va arriver à 26 ans on était il y a 21
ans il y a encore quelques années quand
en 45 il y a eu la réforme faite de
façon très courageux c'était dit la
réforme de la mort la retraite parce que
l'espérance de vie elle était tellement
limitée que c'était 4 ans la retraite
donc il faut tenir compte tout cela est
parallèlement vous avez les cotisants
qui alors le but simplement nous pensons
nous qu'il faut que les retraités qui
ont travaillé toute leur vie et encore
plus longtemps demain est une retraite à
hauteur du niveau de vie moyen c'est
pour ça que l'effort qu'on demande en
travaillant davantage ces personnes là
qu'on va demander on a convaincu le
gouvernement par rapport aux 62 ans
toujours d'Emmanuel Macron à son premier
mandat cet effort ils vont en avoir
derrière les retours à travers une
retraite qui savent plus signific dire
que ce qu'ils auraient eu si nous ne
touchions à rien vous faites référence à
cet argument la retraite pour les morts
c'est exactement ce que Boris Vallot le
président du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale a utilisé dans
l'un de ses discours écouter le
mais disons-le au gouvernement c'est
très réforme c'est la retraite pour les
morts aujourd'hui vous le savez il y a
un quart des plus pauvres des Français
qui sont déjà mort à 62 ans c'est quoi
le projet de ce gouvernement c'est qu'il
soit encore plus nombreux à 64 ans mais
ils le seront de fait c'est au minimum
10000 morts en plus chaque année qui ne
connaîtront pas la tranquillité d'une
retraite charmant acquise par une vie de
labeur c'est trois fois plus que le
nombre des morts sur les routes est-ce
que vous trouvez ça juste
dans le propos bon tout le monde sait
que dans cette réforme il y a aussi un
salon de dispositif pour pouvoir partir
plus tôt par exemple si vous êtes en
situation d'invalidité ou de handicap
pour pouvoir partir plus tôt c'est déjà
le cas aujourd'hui mais on continue à
élargir ce dispositif et si vous avez
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans vous
pouvez partir à 58 ans si vous avez
commencé à travailler entre 18 et 20 ans
pour partir à 60 ans on élargit la prise
en compte de la pénibilité par exemple
pour pouvoir faciliter les reconversions
la formation tout au long de la vie avec
un examen médical à 45 ans et si on voit
que vous êtes dans une situation de de
pénibilité qui pourrait poser problème
pour la suite de votre carrière à ce
moment-là pouvoir vraiment avoir accès à
des à des formations donc évidemment
qu'on est sensible à cette question du
des travailleurs pauvres des
travailleurs en situation d'invalidité
c'est tout l'objet justement de pouvoir
aussi mieux financer notre système de
retraite c'est de pouvoir l'améliorer
pour tenir
encore payé par les travailleurs les
plus pauvres c'est ça l'une des
critiques que qui s'exprime bon on me
dit que vous répondez à ça et ensuite
elle pourra détailler elle est payée par
tous les travailleurs c'est la façon
dont fonctionne notre système de
retraite c'est que les cotisants
cotisent pour les retraités c'est un
système par répartition et c'est un
système par répartition
intergénérationnelle pourquoi dites-vous
oui mais elle est payée par les
travailleurs les plus pauvres qui va
travailler plus on l'a vu la génération
la plus concernée ça va elle ça va être
celle des années 65 et 66 et ça commence
dès la génération 61 c'est-à-dire ceux
qui partent à la retraite cette année
s'ils ont une carrière complète c'est
eux qui vont devoir travailler plus donc
c'est le plus pauvre dans cette danse
des génération là attendez moi je parle
surtout et sur il y a pas que les plus
pauvres mais ce dont je vous parle c'est
ceux qui sont prêts à partir à la
retraite c'est ce qui devait partir là
cette année l'année prochaine et dans
deux ans cela la plupart du temps donc
vraiment en pourcentage élevé des
situations ils ils ont commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans souvent ils ont
les métiers manuels difficiles les moins
bien payés c'est à eux qu'on va demander
de travailler entre
6 mois et 2 ans de plus pour certains
c'est moi le dispositifs le dispositif
des carrières longues préservé ce ayant
commencé à travailler avant 16 ans pour
en partir des 58 ans entre 16 et 18 à
partir de 60 ans entre 18 et 20 à 62 ans
d'accord rentrer dans les détails parce
que de savoir combien de Français ont
cinq trimestre
aussi la prise en compte une meilleure
prise en compte des apprentis par
exemple les trimestres que vous avez
cumulées en étant apprenti ça
aujourd'hui c'est un départ du système
qui fonctionne pas très bien seront
mieux pris en compte pour pouvoir partir
à la retraite plutôt alors le le titre
ne fonctionne pas très bien quand même
le titre de notre débat vous voyez
depuis quelques minutes retraite
l'embrasement est-il inévitable on va
venir sur cette question la France
peut-elle se payer le luxe d'une crise
sociale dans un contexte d'inflation
avec un risque de récession Mathieu le
front syndical a appelé à une première
journée de mobilisation jeudi prochain
il va y avoir du monde dans les rues oui
mais du monde dans les rues parce que
quand lui confédération syndicale appel
à manifester ça fait généralement du
monde plus la fonction publique rentre
dans la danse donc on sera dans une
démonstration de force d'ailleurs c'est
le but des syndicats frapper vite et
fort à la fois parce que le débat
parlementaire risque d'être court entre
guillemets il y a 15 jours prévu à
l'assemblée de débat en février puis
ensuite évidemment le Sénat et puis
ensuite parce qu'il fallait pas laisser
l'initiative alors là c'est vraiment des
Bizzbee entre syndicats et partis
politiques contestataire fallait pas
laisser l'initiative de la mobilisation
à la France insoumise qui elle avait
déjà calé le 21 janvier et donc du coup
ça donne le 19 le 19 janvier une la
première journée de mobilisation parce
que la mobilisation doit s'inscrire dans
la durée et puis enfin il y aura du
monde parce que c'est pour la première
fois depuis 12 ans ben il y a un front
uni des syndicats il fallait donc
marquer le coup d'ailleurs vous avez vu
à qui est revenu l'honneur de lire le
communiqué commun regardez
pour construire une réponse commune de
mobilisation interprofessionnelle
celle-ci prendra la forme d'une première
journée de grève et de manifestation le
19 janvier 2023
de la CFDT le premier syndicat de France
le plus réformiste puisque la CFDT qui
n'a pas été la seule mais à accompagné
ou soutenu différentes réformes par le
passé dans les deux dernières d'ailleurs
la réforme systémique promise par
Emmanuel Macron débute son quinquennat
qui ne s'est pas faite et puis la
précédente celle de proposer par rapport
Marisol Touraine sous François Hollande
et puis donc voilà il faut faire vite
effort et je disais vite parce que dans
les rangs du France syndical on se dit
tiens les réformistes sont avec nous il
y a la CFDT il y a l'USA il y a la CFTC
et il y a des doutes sur le fait qu'il
reste pendant tout le mouvement donc
autant faire ça il fallait des fois tout
de suite voilà et les Français alors
c'est la grande question est-ce qu'ils
vont suivre alors c'est là qu'on a connu
sur le papier ils auraient de bonnes
raisons de se mobiliser si on va croire
les sondages parce qu'ils sont
majoritairement opposés à la réforme et
en particulier à la mesure d'âge pour
beaucoup en fait il y a même la
nécessité c'est un peu le sens de notre
débat ici de la réforme qui n'aimait pas
bien comprises pas forcément accepté
puis les raisons d'être colère elles
existent la réforme est rapide et donc
brutale le rythme des efforts demandés
se fait un peu à la hussarde
généralement les réformes et
s'appliquent sur 8-10 ans ça pour le
coup c'est le cas par le passé c'est le
cas pour cette réforme là mais là ça
commence tout de suite et c'est ce que
vous soulignez tout à l'heure c'est vrai
que c'est rare que on revoit comme ça
les générations tout le monde a pris sa
calculatrice qui vont être mises à
contribution et puis on en parlait le
calendrier de la précédente réforme
Touraine est accéléré et puis un climat
grande sociale ou l'avez vu dans les
transports l'hôpital donc il y a des
raisons de croire que ça peut péter
comme on dit oui mais voilà la
mobilisation ça ne se décrète pas ça se
constate après une fois que c'est dans
la rue et une semaine c'est court pour
mobiliser et puis il y a d'autres
raisons qui permettent d'en douter
d'abord parce que c'est plus dur c'est
plus difficile de mobiliser aujourd'hui
parce que il y a des par exemple un
Français sur trois qui pratiquent le
travail le télétravail régulièrement les
gens sont moins entreprises c'est dur
aussi parce que faire grève ça coûte et
qu'on est quand même dans une crise
absolue du pouvoir d'achat donc l'impact
peut faire mal un jour de grève de jour
de grève sur la feuille de paye et puis
aussi parce que les Français sont
ambivalents à un institut élab les a
interrogés pour BFM TV hier soir après
la présentation de la réforme par
Elisabeth borne si Français sur 10 s'il
déclarés opposés mais plus de 7 Français
sur 10 pensez au final que la réforme
serait adoptée en gros la question c'est
savoir si c'est la colère qu'il en poste
ou la résignation voir la lassitude car
pour se mobiliser faut y croire faut
être sûr de pouvoir renverser la table
et les syndicats en jouant agitent le
souvenir de 95 mais on peut aussi agiter
le souvenir de la réforme verte 2010 14
journées mobilisation entre mars et
novembre parfois deux minutes jusqu'à 2
millions de personnes dans dans la rue
pour certaines ce qui n'a pas empêché la
réforme d'être voté et appliquée
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous dans
nos propositions nous formulons depuis
un certain nombre d'années nous avions
bien dit qu'il fallait faire confiance
aux partenaires sociaux et nous donnions
un an avec quelques cadrages aux
partenaires sociaux pour se mettre
d'accord justement sur un certain nombre
de dispositifs ça nous a pas échappé la
pénibilité les carrières longues la
prise en compte des carrières des femmes
qui n'est pas suffisamment prise en
compte encore derrière un format même si
elle rentre dans les carrières longues
je vais vous dire tout ça pour qu'elle
ait travaillé avant de 16 ans alors
c'est un peu compliqué quand même et
donc tous ces dispositifs c'est des
négociations syndicales qui peut mieux
que nous dire ce que c'est que la
pénibilité comment faut l'apprendre
c'est pas de Paris qu'on va leur dire
les critères qu'il faut avoir etc c'est
eux qui doivent nous faire remarquer
avec vous l'aviez déjà de pas donné
pardon
vous l'aviez déjà pris d'une certaine
façon lors du premier capital Macron non
mais dans la première version systémique
j'avais eu un longtemps de discussion de
négociation etc pourquoi pas cette
fois-ci alors non mais c'est pas vrai
c'est qu'il y a quand même deux éléments
distincts tous les éléments gérés
qualitatifs c'est-à-dire la pénibilité
les carrés longues les carrières hachées
etc là il y a eu un dialogue qui a été
mené plutôt constructif entre la
première ministre et les partenaires
sociaux et même d'ailleurs à s'attendre
de voir type d'opposition aujourd'hui le
position elle se cristallise sur la
mesure d'âge bon et à partir du moment
où tous les syndicats effectivement
refusent aujourd'hui cette question de
mesure d'âge que nous nous considérons
comme étant dans l'intérêt général et un
enjeu de responsabilité le présent
République y était engagé dans sa dans
sa campagne même si vous rappeler qu'il
avait parlé au départ de 65 ans il y a
aussi eu ce dialogue qui a permis
d'évoluer sur 64 ans avec l'accélération
du calendrier de la réforme Touraine et
aussi avec les syndicats ou avec le
parti LRD 65 à 64 mais les deux mais
c'est important il y a un dialogue
parlementaire évidemment il y a attendez
il faut d'abord aussi construire une
majorité au Parlement et ce dialogue
politique il est tout de même important
et on a pu constater effectivement il y
a les positions d'élèves au Sénat depuis
longtemps et il y a eu un dialogue
constructif je pense avec LR à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est important et
le dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
sur les enjeux type pénibilité car
l’argent etc de dialogue avec les
partenaires sociaux comme il le disent
eux-mêmes c'est surtout ce qu'on appelle
promener le chien parce que à chaque
fois qu'ils avaient chez Isabelle borne
il disait ton projet maintenant je veux
pas à vous d'abord il joue à ni oui ni
non pendant 3 mois
c'est la différence entre ce que ce que
Emmanuel Macron a fait pendant son
premier quinquennat ou les retraites
pris le temps de consulter il avait même
nommé un bon souvenir un
haut-commissaire en retraite ou je sais
plus quel était son titre
voilà donc il y avait pris le temps et
donc parce que c'était un sujet
compliqué alors c'était la réforme
systémique et là et là plus on attend ce
que vous êtes précisément en train de
dire c'est que ça fait des années qu'il
y a ce dialogue avec les partenaires
sociaux sur les retraites ça fait des et
après il y a eu il y a eu des
interrompus il y a eu des interruptions
parce qu'il y a eu covid etc mais ça
fait des années effectivement qui a un
dialogue permanent avec les partenaires
avec les partenaires sociaux qui a eu
ces concertations il y a eu après une
élection présidentielle ou le président
s'est engagé formellement à cette
réforme je me rappelle quand même d'un
certain nombre de candidats et de
présidents qui se sont pas engagés sur
des mesures aussi un populaire que la
réforme des retraites dans une campagne
présidentielle François Hollande en 2012
a dit qu'il reviendrait à 60 ans il a
jamais fait bon donc
on l'a on l'a promis on s'y engagé pour
la campagne présidentielle après il
avait été question d'ailleurs peut-être
de faire un amendement délété ou la
rentrée on a repoussé ce calendrier pour
pouvoir avoir ce dialogue mais à un
moment c'est effectivement c'est un
enjeu de responsabilité de faire cette
réforme autre vous avez donné quelques
éléments venant des instituts de
sondages j'en propose un autre son
agifoque pour Fiducial et Sud Radio avec
cette idée d'explosion sociale voilà les
termes qui sont employés dans dans la
question c'est le choix de nos confrères
52% des Français souhaitent que la
France connaisse dans les prochains mois
une explosion sociale Monique Lubin
est-ce que vous reprenez parce que la
gauche les syndicats il y a ce front uni
pour l'instant des parties de gauche et
des syndicats
d'explosion sociale je ne voilà je ne
souhaite pas une explosion sociale je
souhaite une réaction forte je souhaite
que les salariés se mobilisent oui mais
comme on a l'habitude de se mobiliser en
France c'est-à-dire de manière certes
comment dire ferme mais sereine aussi
enfin je ne non je ne veux pas je ne
veux pas de pagaille dans du pays non je
ne veux pas ça mais je pense que les
salariés doivent se mobiliser parce que
le gouvernement est sourd le
gouvernement est sourd et que pour la la
seule façon de faire reculer le
gouvernement c'est effectivement une
mobilisation importante moi je voudrais
revenir sur notamment les carrières
longues le discours ambiant les éléments
de langage laissent penser qu'on n'a pas
touché aux carrières longues l'arbre qui
cache la forêt c'est pourront partir à
58 ans ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler à 16 ans ça représentera
franchement très très peu de gens donc
c'est vraiment l'arbre qui cache la
forêt par contre aujourd'hui l'essentiel
des gens qui ont des carrières longues
sont ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 20 ans qui ont cotisé cinq
trimestres avant 20 ans ils ont entre 18
et 20 ans cela ils prennent deux ans de
plus vous pouvez le tourner comme vous
voulez ils prennent deux ans de plus à
partir de 2030 deux ans complet et ça
commence dès cette année c'est à dire
qu'au lieu d'être longtemps ça sera 60
ans et trois mois et ainsi de suite donc
non les carrières longues ne sont pas
maintenues telles qu'elles le soir
la dernière chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que on se glorifie du fait que on
va pouvoir continuer à partir avec
invalidité et tout ça moi je réponds
encore heureux c'est tout juste s'il
faudrait pas c'est tout juste il
faudrait pas vous remercier parce que
c'est maintenu non je dis encore heureux
et on sait très bien c'est très
compliqué de partir pour invalidité très
compliqué bon allez je reprends la main
parce que dans nos débats sur les
retraites il y en a il y en aura
évidemment plusieurs dans les dans les
jours et les semaines qui qui viennent
on va régulièrement vous donner la
parole voici trois réactions qui ont
attiré notre attention là c'est le coup
de massue
ça empêche les gens de se projeter de
profiter surtout pour des gens qui ont
des un travail qui peut être très très
physique et ou avec une charge mentale
je vais mettre du pécule côté pour ma
retraite mais moi je sais qu'il faut que
je travaille jusqu'à la fin j'ai
travaillé pendant 15-16 ans en
exploitation laitière je sais que les
retraites ne sont pas
très élevés donc il faut que je
travaille pour avoir les 1200 euros et
c'est pas sûr que je les aurais deux ans
de plus enfin je trouve ça c'est
vraiment dingue en fait d'aller
aussi loin en fait je trouve on savait
que ça allait arriver et j'espère que il
y aura des gosses pas une manifestation
moi je pense je vais aller manifester de
mon côté si c'est assez rare mais là je
vais le faire voilà c'est intéressant ce
qui n'ont pas l'habitude de manifester
et qui se disent tient cette fois-ci je
vais peut-être y aller René Paul Savary
un conflit social surtout si dur on sait
que ça peut coûter cher notamment aux
produits intérieur brut de s de de notre
pays est-ce que vous craignez ça bien
sûr ça peut coûter cher je crois que il
faut une explication faut de la clarté
il faut de la confiance
l'explication jusqu'à présent
il faut le faire même s'il y a ce risque
de conflit social qui coûtera cher à
d'autres pays si jamais le bon moment et
derrière il faut savoir que
pour faire en sorte qu'on arrive à
équilibrer notre système social auquel
tout le monde est attaché il y a un
certain nombre
qui doivent être compris et acceptés
donc acceptable par la population donc
on sait très bien que il faut prendre un
certain nombre de risques effectivement
et confrontés cette opinion publique qui
peut être hostile mais aussi parce que
il y a une absence de climat de
confiance si ça s'était passé par
exemple moi par faire ça mais lors de
son premier quinquennat Emmanuel Macron
qu'une de ses premières réformes suite
été effectivement quelque chose de bien
cadré solide correspondant par exemple à
ce modèle là ça serait passé bien
différemment on n'était pas dans les
mêmes circonstances mais pendant cinq
ans il y a pas eu de vision on a arrêté
un truc et puis maintenant on passe le
contraire moi juste un mot je suis en
train de reprendre l'étude d'impact de
la réforme du système universel on
disait dans cette étude la première la
première la première réforme
du système par répartition tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui avec les durées de
cotisations la prise en compte des
annuités qu'est-ce qu'on n'allait pas
réformer là et finalement à vouloir tout
bouger on a rien bougé et donc le
président mais cinq ans quand même pour
comprendre que on pouvait adapter la
réforme par des mesures paramétriques
mais si on les avait-il prises petit à
petit ces mesures elles ont pu être
comprise par la population et donc là
elles arrivent de façon brutale parce
que avant de partir je veux vraiment
remettre les trucs à l'équilibre de ça
mais enfin vous avez déjà un peu répondu
mais voilà vous êtes de nouveau pour
sauver là dessus pourquoi ce changement
de pied c'est vrai que ces deux systèmes
de réformes totalement différentes mais
c'est vrai et il y a eu une ambition au
premier mandat d'essayer de faire cette
réforme du système universel et je crois
que la conclusion sur laquelle on a
abouti c'est que c'est très complexe
c'était très complexe à mettre en œuvre
c'était très complexe à expliquer
effectivement on arrive maintenant sur
un système paramétrique plus classique
où on prend le système actuel et en
revanche pour essayer de préserver sa
pérennité financière on décale l'âge de
mais avec Harris
on a l'impression que c'est un Favre qui
occulte avec un avec un élément oui mais
encore une fois sur c'est le levier
qu'on utilise notre travail de pédagogie
auprès de France mais il y a ce travail
de pédagogie à faire et on va continuer
à le faire à expliquer l'importance de
le réformer pour pouvoir préserver notre
notre système après sur l'idée que ce
serait mieux passé pendant le premier
mandat moi je dirais quand même deux
éléments là-dessus déjà je partage
totalement à l'analyse du sénateur ça
varie sur le fait qu'il y ait jamais de
bons moments ce qui vous dise ou alors
il y a les gilets jaunes et puis après
il y a eu covid et puis après la guerre
en Ukraine est pris l'énergie mais dans
6 mois tout ira mieux il y aura pas de
crise géopolitique et on aura un climat
apaisé cette crise de confiance crise de
confiance généralisée vis-à-vis de
l'autorité des politiques que tout qui
touche toutes nos démocraties et il
suffira dès le Brésil ou les États-Unis
et nos voisins donc là aussi on voit
bien qu'on est dans ce dans ce contexte
là donc soyons humbles aussi par rapport
à cela mais ça nous empêche pas de
devoir prendre des mesures responsables
deuxième élément quand même par rapport
au premier mandat c'est que là tout de
même on a une campagne présidentielle il
y a six mois je me répète mais où le
présent République a dit explicitement
dans la comédie présidentielle comme
législatives c'était surtout notre acte
qu'il voulait faire cette réforme et
qu'il voulait la faire alors à 65 ans
donc au moins il y a eu un effort de
pédagogie et d'honnêteté intellectuelle
avant de s'embarquer dans cette réforme
ce travail de pédagogie il passe aussi
évidemment par le Parlement et le Sénat
quand un calmé vous pouvez nous
rejoindre bonsoir Quentin les attaques
venaient essentiellement des bancs de la
gauche aujourd'hui au cinéma il y avait
comme tous les mercredis les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement ils avaient
de borne les ministres qui viennent
répondre comme ça aux questions 16
questions des sénateurs et on l'a
compris depuis le début de cette
émission la droite vote depuis 2018 une
réforme qui ressemble à celle présentée
hier donc les critiques venaient
effectivement des bancs de la gauche les
sénateurs de gauche qui parlent de
mesure injustes socialement et c'est
vous Monique Lubin élu des Landes qui
avait évoqué vos amis vos proches qui
ont commencé à travailler jeunes et qui
voit la perspective de partir à la
retraite s'éloigner vous avez pu évoquer
ce cas de figure devant le ministre du
Travail et écoutez un extrait de sa
réponse c'était un peu sec
la vérité madame la sénatrice elle est
peut-être sur deux points le premier
c'est que les exemples que vous avez
cités les amis que vous avez auquel vous
avez pensé je souhaite pour vous que ce
soit des amis imaginaires parce que le
principal bouger le principal décalage
de la rage de départ c'est la hausse de
la durée de cotisation vous avez voté en
2013 et la deuxième chose que je vais
vous dire c'est quand vous écoutant et
je j'ai en tête les propos du
responsable du parti socialiste qui
s'est converti à la doctrine de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous avez ainsi perdu le sens
de la raison et de la responsabilité
un petit peu la broncale dans
l'hémicycle qui s'est fait c'était assez
surprenant comme ça depuis la tribune de
presse on l'a bien entendu vous avez
répliqué ensuite Monique Lubin vous avez
eu du mal à la garder pour vous ce rire
un peu nerveux qu'à vous le savez
Olivier du subt et lui-même est su
dérange du Parti socialiste qui a quitté
en 2010 pour rejoindre le gouvernement
d'Édouard Philippe et donc Monique Lubin
vous n'avez pas manqué lui rappeler qu'à
l'époque et ben il était hostile à une
mesure d'âge sur la réforme des
retraites en écoute en extrait qu'il est
doux à mes oreilles de vous de me faire
des remarques à moi sur ce qu'a fait ma
famille politique et ce que nous avons
voté quand ça vient de vous monsieur le
ministre vous et moi savons très bien
[Applaudissements]
pouvez séparer les deux hommes au Palais
Bourbon et sont aussi une autre
explication du fait que ce soit encore
plus savoureux cet échange aujourd'hui
madame Lubin merci beaucoup Quentin pour
ces pour cette dernière anecdote
Monique Lubin ça vous fait rire jaune
parce qu'on peut on parle de d'Olivier
du socle mais on pourrait aussi parler
de la première ministre Élisabeth borde
qui a été 5 ans au cabinet de Lionel
ministre ça me fait pas rire du tout
parce que franchement Olivier du socle
m'a provoqué clairement quand il me dit
vous avez voté en 2013 enfin il était
député socialiste donc voilà il y a des
choses qui vaut mieux quand même éviter
de dire et puis bon mais ça c'est c'est
anecdotique non ça me fait pas rire du
tout parce que moi vous voyez j'ai
beaucoup de mal je je suis élue depuis
longtemps pas parlementaire depuis
longtemps mais élu depuis longtemps je
sais bien que il y a ce qu'on aimerait
faire et puis il y a ce que quelquefois
la réalité ne nous permet pas de faire
ou nous oblige à faire donc bon je j'ai
un peu de recul sur la vie politique et
je sais prendre mes responsabilités et
quand je dois aller prendre mais de là à
carrément changé de cap changer de
famille politique être capable de dire
un jour l'exact inverse de ce que l'on
disait trois ou quatre ans avant c'est
un membre je ne peux pas je ne l'ai pas
senti européenne
des sociodémocrate qui sont restés
sociaux-démocrates et européen mais
attendez
je suis membre du Parti socialiste je ne
suis pas membre de notre parti politique
de la gauche d'accord et moi vous pouvez
regarder mon histoire politique je suis
membre du Parti socialiste depuis 35 ans
contre venses et marais je ne suis pas
allé chercher ailleurs quand le bateau
coulé je suis toujours là fidèle à ma
famille et fidèle à mes convictions
François Hollande enfin Emmanuel Macron
a comme été ministre de François
vous êtes un problème de casting
c'est que je me dis que décidément il y
a peut-être une évolution qui n'était
pas celle que je j'espérais peut-être
pour ça d'ailleurs que moi j'y suis
toujours et que eux n'y sont plus tiens
on va prendre avec quelques minutes pour
pour parler de l'index senior je suis en
régie vous l'aviez vous allez me suivre
cette index seniors pour valoriser les
entreprises qui gardent leurs salariés
les plus âgés en écoutant les Abd born
sur ce thème les entreprises doivent
faire leur place aux personnes proches
de la retraite et veiller à une
meilleure qualité de vie au travail il
est temps que les employeurs prennent en
main ce sujet
un index sera créé sur la place des
salariés en fin de carrière cette index
sera simple il sera public il permettra
de valoriser les bonnes pratiques et de
dénoncer les mauvaises le construire
sera obligatoire pour les entreprises de
plus de 1000 salariés dès cette année et
en 2024 pour celle de plus de 300
salariés allez en termes avec un tour de
table rapide sur ce thème René Paul
savarydex surtout après il faut
simplement faire une communication on
est montré du doigt si on n'a pas
communiqué on a travaillé pour les
entreprises qui travaillent leur marque
employeur c'est important on a travaillé
sur l'emploi des seniors avec Monique
lumin le maintien des seigneurs en
emploi et notamment ce qu'on proposait
nous le saloit le numéro 6 de la
proposition c'était que au niveau de
discussion dans les
RSE des entreprises il y a une gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois tenant compte
des seniors et de voir comment on
faisait le maintien et l'adaptation de
l'emploi en fin de parcours de ces gens
là avec un contrat bilatéral et si ce
contrat n'était pas respecté il y avait
des décisions unilatérales et c'est ce
que je vais proposer moi me semble-t-il
aux partenaires sociaux qui sont
véritablement à la Hamen et on fait
confiance au chef d'entreprise pour
régler avec leur collaborateurs
justement cette histoire
et vous savez que c'est effectivement ne
suffit pas et nous nous sommes posés
beaucoup de questions quand nous avons
travaillé avec René Paul Savary est-ce
qu'il faut de l'incitation de la
coercition tout ce qui a été essayé
jusqu'à maintenant n'a pas fonctionné
René Paul Savary parle de confiance
oui moi je veux bien faire confiance
mais enfin jusqu'à maintenant et et
depuis que nous les avons nous avons
commis ce rapport que nous avons
auditionné rien n'a bougé c'est-à-dire
que le Medef visiblement reconnaît que
il n'a toujours pas de plan pour
l'emploi des seniors coercitives
vis-à-vis des entreprises qui ne moi je
pense en tout cas je pense en tout cas
que un moment il faut trouver une
solution pour interdire aux entreprises
qui se bien de faire des plans de
licenciement on m'a encore parlé d'un
plan de licenciement aujourd'hui dans
une entreprise à forte valeur ajoutée
qui va payer des gens pendant des années
pour qu'elle quitte l'entreprise je veux
dire
ça n'est plus possible allez à vous le
mot de la fin Benjamin date sur cette
question c'est vrai que c'est un peu bon
c'est un peu le service minimum si je
veux dire
que l'index il y a aussi par exemple la
possibilité encore une fois de faciliter
favoriser renforcer la formation pour
les seniors ce que montre par exemple le
rapport humain sabbat Savary c'est que
les seniors utilisent moins la formation
que le reste de la population active
donc ça je pense que c'est très
important les entreprises de proposer
des plans de formation à partir de 50
ans et parfois même avant mais peut-être
mais vous avez raison tout à fait
renforcer aussi le cumul emploi retraite
encore plus ce qui a permis aussi
d'augmenter le taux d'emploi des seniors
ces dernières années par rapport à ce
que c'était auparavant l'index il y a
quelque chose qui est très intéressant
dans votre le rapport c’est la question
culturelle en fait vous dites qu'en
réalité il y a un biais culturel contre
le fait d'employer de manière les
seniors dans l'emploi dans les
entreprises en France comparé à d'autres
pays européens donc ça c'est vraiment
une question qui doit nous interpeller
j'espère que l'index est avec un index
qui peut aussi mener à des sanctions
peut contribuer aussi à créer un débat
là-dessus peut-être que ça suffira pas
mais en tout cas je pense que c'est une
vraie priorité dans les prochains jours
merci à tous les trois d'avoir participé
à ce premier débat à bientôt évidemment
sur sur public